between humanity and the open water  marine protected areas enable the ocean  to rejuvenate  without human interference  they serve as replenishment zones for  fisheries  and provide safe harbors for entire  ecosystems  68 of what the fishermen are catching  right now is from the spillover effect  of an mpa  it's bringing tourism into the area  that fish is worth more  alive  than it is dead on the airplane  maybe having a marine reserve and  building a tourism industry  is one way that we can create a future  a  marina  so  stewardship of our ocean  is not a one-person event  it's a universal requirement all across  this planet  you